like millions of people across this  country i woke up this morning  sad and rueful but also filled with  pride and  hope and with thanks to gareth southgate  and the whole england squad  for the best campaign by any england  team in any  tournament that i can remember they made  history  they lifted our spirits they brought joy  to this country and i know that they  will continue to do so  and to those who have been directing  racist  abuse at some of the players i said  shame on you and i hope you will crawl  back under the rock  from which you emerged because this  entire team played like heroes  and i'm sure that this is just the  beginning of their achievements and i  say  bring on qatar next year and let's also  dare to start to hope that together with  ireland  our united kingdom can host the world  cup  in 2030.